had a productive discussion with the
trade unions yesterday the key focus of
the meeting was to look at next year's
pay review body and the evidence that we
submit to that we want to work
constructively with the unions in terms
of the evidence that is submitted there
and obviously building on what has come
out from the OVR and what is Affordable
to the wide economy but of course as
part of that meeting we also listened to
the trade unions in terms of their
concerns in respect of this year that's
part of a wider discussion that is
happening across government where other
departments other secretaries of state
are meeting with their trade unions and
of course I will take those messages
back from the health unions in terms of
my discussions with the chancellor
for the right process is to look at next
year's independent pay-per-view body we
believe as a government that The
Independents or the pay review Body
Matters and that is the right way
forward indeed the opposition have said
that they themselves support the
pay-per-view body process so it's right
that we use that as the the main
mechanism and we work together with the
trade unions to recognize the cost of
living pressures that there are on staff
across the economy but including within
the NHS so we want to get the evidence
into the pay review body right and work
constructively on that but of course as
part of that discussion the trade unions
also emphasize that for them this year
was also important we're having a
conversation across government with
trade unions because obviously this
impacts our number of departments and I
will take those messages back in my
discussions with the chancellor
the Prime Minister the government's been
consistent throughout that we have an
independent pay-per-view body uh process
and that is the right way forward and
we've been consistent on that and that
is why uh given not least that we're
more than three quarters away through we
don't think it would be appropriate to
go back to last April to retrospectively
go back all those months in terms of
what has already happened this year we
had a process that looked at the issues
in the round but at the same time you
want to listen to the trade unions want
to engage with them constructively you
want to get the right evidence into the
pay-per-view body next year and of
course they made further representations
in terms of this year notwithstanding
that we're more than three quarters of
the way through the year and it is right
that we listen to those concerns
what I'm saying is we're particularly
focused on the pay-per-view body which
will start from a thankful that is the
right approach and we've been consistent
on that but at the same time we're
engaging we're listening we're working
with Trade union colleagues because we
recognize there's very real pressure on
the health system at the moment and as
part of that obviously it is not helpful
to have the strikes tomorrow that is a
concern in terms of ambulances a key
part of my visit today is to see the
Fantastic work that the team are doing
here at London Central and West they
take over 600 000 111 calls a year they
do a formidable job in terms of dealing
with urgent calls of course if people
have an urgent call issue it is
important that they call 111 if they
have an emergency then of course 999 but
there will be pressure on the system
tomorrow so it's important that people
are bearing that in mind in terms of
calling 111 if it's an urgent matter do
you want to on the level of anger among
health workers on the suggested that
they should work harder for any pain
well that wasn't said in the meeting and
the Trade union leader that made those
comments outside the Departments of
Health bizarrely wasn't actually in the
meeting on which he was commenting and I
saw he did a media round again this
morning talking about a meeting that he
wasn't actually at but there is common
ground with the trade unions in terms of
how do we ensure that clinicians who are
highly trained are focused on clinical
work and not having to divert time on
Administration on some of the
frustrating tasks that they have to do
how do we get the right Tech Support to
them how do we work better across the
system as a whole so I think there's an
important difference between working
better working in ways across the whole
NHS family that ensure patients are
treated in the right place at the right
time and that maximizes the clinical
skills particularly of our nursing staff
and that is something that the train
engine themselves welcome in terms of
ensuring that some of the things that
are very frustrating for staff around
for example technology we work in a
better way on that that's very different
to the comments that were made by
someone who wasn't actually in the room
about a meeting they hadn't actually
attended
well we recognized in our I gave a
statement to the House of Commons
yesterday recognizing they're very
severe pressure particularly emergency
departments have faced of course the
significant pressure as a consequence of
flu we've seen a seven-fold increase in
the number of flu cases compared to last
month a hundred times the number of
people in hospital with flu compared to
last year and that of course comes on
top of a high number of missions from
covid and also a backlog in terms of
delayed discharge as a consequence of
the pandemic and a further challenge of
the spiking flu that we've faced is that
also has an impact in terms of Supply
because stuff absence is also higher
when you have those flu spikes so we've
had a number of factors come together
that's created very significant pressure
that's why in the House of Commons
yesterday I announced a further 250
million pounds of funding that we've
re-prioritized within our budget
responding to what I have heard over
Christmas
in terms of the pressures faced by the
system listening particularly to the
front line in emergency departments who
said that they wanted some further
capacity which were put into place
through modular capacity but also in
particular A Renewed focus on delayed
discharge so we targeted that in the
Autumn statement the extra 500 million
pounds that local authorities and
integrated care boards have been rolling
out we sell out a further 200 million
pounds yesterday in the House of Commons
responding to the the very real concerns
that have been raised with me it shows
that we're listening and acting on those
pressures that the front line is facing